et autour enfonce avant de refermer ce
journal avec quelques centaines
d'agriculteurs qui ont manifesté
aujourd'hui devant le tribunal d'agen
ils étaient près de 700 venus avec une
trentaine de tracteurs devant
l'institution ils ont manifesté en
soutien à deux agriculteurs condamné en
première instance à deux ans de prison
ferme pour avoir creusé illégalement un
lac à caussade le lac a été creusé pour
permettra d'irriguer les zones les plus
sèches de la région elle écrit culture
présent pour soutenir leurs confrères ne
comprennent pas ces décisions écouter
station et est unique elle est
extrêmement sévère puisque avec la
révocation de sursis pour des histoires
anciennes voilà ça c'est d'abord la
prison ferme qui a demandé plusieurs
mois et jusqu'à une année au total sans
oublier des amendes à une amende de plus
de 5000 euros qui sont demandées à titre
à titre personnel alors je me questionne
quant effectivement je vois tout un tas
de délinquants avait des fautes que l'on
pourra juger cdr que les citoyens
souvent sévères et qu'ils sont
une pas condamner quasiment relaxés ou
condamnés à des peines extrêmement
légère la prison ferme a vocation à
retirer des gens de la circulation parce
qu'ils ont ils peuvent nuire aux
populations je ne vois pas en quoi ces
garçons qui sont éminemment respectable
nuisent à la société ils y apportent au
contraire énormément